this morning we want to tell you about a
remarkable Innovation that's changing
the way Timeless artists created for
centuries world famous Carrera marble
has been used to make some of the most
iconic sculptures in history by famous
artists like Michelangelo his Creations
took hundreds I mean hundreds of hours
now as Chris livesay shows us a new type
of artist is speeding up the process of
bringing art to life
it was the marble of Michelangelo Canova
and now it's called one L
a robot 3
feet of zinc alloy doing the work of an
army of Renaissance sculptors says
Giacomo Masari the owner of robitor the
company behind this invention is working
right now on uh on avinos on a Venus
culture
I think it's going to take about four
days four or five days and how long
would it have taken you before 1l got
the job a couple of months that's a good
employee
it doesn't go on a holiday it doesn't
get sick does it even sleep
crafting statues at an industrial scale
and speed is coated with the with a
diamond powder diamonds synthetic
diamond powder yeah it's the the best
cutting system in the very Hills of
Carrara where Michelangelo sourced the
marble for his David and pieta today art
stars like Jeff Coons and Maurizio
Catalan work closely with Giacomo first
to transform their ideas into 3D images
then sculpt them into Blockbusters of
their own with a Precision that's super
human so this is like the Photoshop of
sculpture
yeah more or less yes it saves a lot of
waste and if there is something that is
wrong or you don't like it you can just
go back the cool thing about about also
this technology is that we allow the
artists to think without any limit
thanks to a Synergy of software and
Robotics that might be the real work of
art
what do you say to somebody who's
scandalized by this who'd say
Michelangelo would be rolling in his
grave robot technology doesn't steal the
job of the humans but just improves it
Some Humans however might disagree
here in the workshop of the Florence
cathedral sculptors like Lorenzo couch
and I have maintained and repaired the
cathedral's vast inventory of marble
statues for centuries the old-fashioned
way it is
we risk forgetting how to work with our
hands he says I hope that a certain
know-how and knowledge will always
remain although the more we go forward
the harder it will be
but even he admits his profession can't
remain anchored to Old Technologies
Outsourcing is nothing new Renaissance
Masters including Michelangelo hired
teams of anonymous Artisans who executed
their Concepts today some artists like
Coons and Catalan are upfront about
using the robots others prefer not to
advertise it I think Hearth is related
to the to the thought so if you can
imagine something it's already a unique
piece of art
and with people like us that are just
the Contemporary artisans
uh there are people that bring this idea
to life
modern Artisans are no doubt
extraordinary even they require
old-fashioned humans to apply the
finishing touches
Giacomo says 1l hasn't achieved
Perfection on his own yet how close are
you now are you at 100 not really not
really I think let's say we are in 99 99
but it's still the human touch makes the
makes the difference that one percent is
so important for CBS mornings Chris
lives say Carrara Italy
all right bled so what do you think I'm
a skeptic uh to me my own opinion art is
an expression that comes from the soul
uh every chisel that Michelangelo or
Rodan the most one of the most beautiful
sculptures the kiss that can't come from
a computer you can tell a computer to do
it but that expression of these great
artists Michelangelo Donatello but what
about this done by a computer that a
robot can help an artist create more and
maybe push their art because they have
the opportunity to create more art over
their lifetime
think about that think about that during
the break yes I'll I'll sleep on that
area go see everybody just Googled a
picture of rodan's the kiss and tell me
if you think a machine could have come
up with it they can certainly do it
right but can they
comes from here and Vlad
speaks his truth and wrote down the
Thinker yeah the famous one or that
museum in Paris I miss you